[موسيقى]
اهلا ومرحبا بكم على حوار ضيفنا اليوم هو
ميخائيل كان احد اخطاء بالبترول في روسيا
ودع السجن لمده عشر سنوات من قبل
يعيش في المنفى في لندن حيث يدير منظمه
غير حكوميه اوبن رشا شكرا على هذا الحضور
معنا سيد خضره كوفسكي شكرا لكم
في اوكرانيا منذ سنه تقريبا كيف ترى
الاوضاع هناك هل تعتقد بان حربا بين الحلف
الاطلسي وروسيا هو امر حتمي لا مفر منه
هناك من يتحدث عن امكانيه وقوع حرب عالميه
ثالثه لم يكن ينوي في ان يواجه بشكل مباشر
حلف شمال الاطلسي الناتو
ولكن حاليا
في روسيا الجميل على قناعه
ان الحربله ليست ضده اوكرانيا بل ان الحرب
هي ضد شمال حلف شمال الاطلسي ولهذا
نجح بوتين في حربه في اوكرانيا فاك دون
بريكوت ان تجاوزه لحدود دوله الاطلسي لن
يشكل اشكاليه بالنسبه له
انت ترى اذا حقق بوتين هدفه في اوكرانيا
لانه سينتقل بعد ذلك الى بلدان البلطيق
وهولندا على سبيل المثال
الا على قناعه تامه
لا يمكنهم ان يتوقف
ففي سنه من الحرب
من الروس الوطنيين
وان اوقف بوتين هذه الحرب فمن جهه
لن يتمكن من
تحسين
حاله الشعب
لان هذه الاراضي التي سيسيطر عليها عبئ
كبير ومن جهه اخرى سيتعرض لضغط من هؤلاء
القوميين الوطنيين الروس
وهم كالطوريون
هذه الحاله
لاربع مرات متكرره نجح بوتين في الحاله
مشاكله الانتخابيه باللجوء الى الحرب وما
من سبب
يجعلنا
انه سيلجا الى حرب الخامسه ان كان ذلك
ضروري
في هذه السنه واستعاده جميع اراضيهم بما
فيها القرم
هل سيكون ذلك ان نجحوا نهايه فلاديمير
بوتين
غيرت الدول الاوروبيه موقفها
وهي حاليا تقدم دعما
لاوكرانيا اذا ان غيرت هذا الموقف
اوكرانيا
ستدمر
بالفعل وان
بوتين فانه سيخسر سلطته
هل تعتقد بان الاوكرانيين بدعم من الغرب
قادرون على الانتصار في هذه الحرب ام
العكس اي ان الامر سيكون صعبا جدا لان
اكاديميه بوتين يدرك بانه يراهن على بقائه
في السلطه في هذه الحرب مهما كان الحال
ان الامور ستكون صعبه وهذا
بسبب ثلاثه امور او ظروف ضروريه السبب
الاول
المعارضه الاوكرانيه
هو قدره الاوروبيين من جهه الامريكيين
كذلك بتوفير اسلحه
كميات كافيه لاوكرانيا والسبب
ان اقتنع المجتمع الروسي ان هذه الحرب
حقيقه حرب وليست حرب روسيا وهذا الامر
الثالث هو ما تعمل عليه المعارضه الروسيه
لاثبات هذا واقناع المجتمع الروسي بذلك
انت ترى في كتاباتك وتحليلاتك بان
احتمالات الاطاحه بالنظام من خلال ثوره
داخليه هي ضئيله جدا
يعني ذلك بان اغلبيه الروس يؤيدون رئيسهم
الدعايه
الرسميه
ولكن لا يجب المبالغه في تقييم هذا الدعم
دعم الروس للحرب
ثلاثين بالمئه
من الروس الذين
لا يريدون ان يخالفوا الاوامر ولكن ان فشل
بوتين عسكريا
فالجميع سينقلب ضده وهو يعي ذلك جيدا
بانه بالنسبه لروسيا ليست التخلص من بوتين
هو الامر الصعب بل التخلص من البوتينيه
هل تعتقدون بانه اذا اضطر بوتين للتخلي عن
الحكم بفجل في اوكرانيا
فهذا لا يعني بان خليفته سيكون افضل حالا
بالنسبه لك هل هذا هو التحدي الحقيقي
بالنسبه لكم كمعارضه تجربه خبرتي على مدى
حياتي
اشخاص
حتى اشخاص ديمقراطيين مثل يلسن ما ان
يتمكنوا من كل مقاليد الحكم يصبحون
وبالنسبه لي هذا ليس بالقدر المحتوم
في روسيا يجب ان يتم تقاسم السرعه
يجب اعتماد نظام فيدرالي فعلي برلماني
زم وتعزيز السلطات المحليه
هذا رايي الشخصي وقد لا تتشاطره كل
المعارضه الروسيه سيدي
من قيصر فاضل
تكون لهم نوايا حسنه
هم يرغبون في الواقع ان يكون هذا القيصر
ممثلهم وان يحل محل وهذا ما اناهضه
هنا يجب اقناع الغرب
لان اي شخص
منصب
وجد قيصر في روسيا
فانه لا محاله سيبحث عن عدو خارجي ليصون
سلطته هذه هي القاعده في روسيا وهذا ما
قام به كل قياصره روسيا
وهذا
ليتشبثوا بالحكم ويجب وضع وضع حد لهذا
هناك شخصيه يتم الحديث عنها كثيرا والتي
قد تكون القيصر الجديد الذي يحل محل بوتين
انه رئيس مجموعه الامنيه الخاصه
فقد اصبح طرفا للحرب في اوكرانيا ولكن
البعض يتساءل ان كانت له ربما طموحات
سياسيه اكبر هل يمكنه ان يكون خلفا لبوتين
ام انه مرؤوس فقط يعمل بامره بوتين
حاليا
السيد
مريغوجين خاضع لاوامر بوتين
ولكن ربما في لحظه يمكن للسيد
ان يدعم احد مقربيه
يحل محل بوتين لا اظن بان السيد بريغوجين
يود ويرغب في الحصول على هذه السلطه لنفسه
اذا هناك خطر فعلي وهو ان يحل محل بوتين
رجل مستبد مثله
هذا الخطر فعلي
وهذا ما يجب محاربته دوم يشط يظل اننا
يمكن ان نتغلب على هذا الخط
نظام التوازن بين القوى الذي شيده
يصعب اعاده بناءه
اذا بعد ذهاب بوتين
امضيت عشر سنوات في السجن في ظروف صعبه
جدا احيانا ولا سيما وضعك في عزله وصفتها
بطريقه
11 ونصف في السجن وفي كل ظروف تدابير
امنيه هل تعتقد بان بوتين يريد ابقائه في
السجن هناك ام سيتم الافراج عنه بصوره
مفاجئه على غرار ما حدث معك هل هكذا
سيناريو محتمل
للاسف
اليوم مختلف تماما عن بوتين 2013
من السجن
الشتات يعتبره بوتين خطا
بخروج من السجن ولكن لن يكرر نفس الخطا
معندما سيخرج ناظامي من السجن سيخرج كذلك
المعارضون الاخرون مثل فلاديميرا
واخرون سيخرجون من السجن لان بوتين سيخسر
هذه الحرب
وان ذلك
سيجد نفسه امام محكمه او في المطبخ وانا
ذاك سيحرر كل المعتقل المعتقلين السياسيين
المستقبل هل تتصور ان تطلع بدور رئيسي
فيها ام قررت ربما بانه ينبغي على الاجيال
الجديده ان تواجه هكذا تحدي
ابصل على قلاعه تامه
هذا التحدي تحدي اعاده
تنظيم وبناء النظام الروسي الجديد
سيرفعه
30 40 سنه حاليا
بالنسبه لجيريا جيلنا فاتته هذه الفرصه
فرصه لم نستغلها
ولكنني سابذل كل ما في وسعي لمساعده هذا
الجيل الجديد سيحقق اهدافه
شكرا على الاجابه عن اسئلتنا تابعوا
برامجنا على